okay so think talking about in domain
versus out of them and generalization
we're talking about this question of
sample efficiency we saw that using this
task specific component was actually a
problem okay because we have to fine
tune them on each task we have to fine
tune them and they are like limiting how
efficient we can do like they are like
increasing the number of sample we need
to learn the target task that we have at
the end and this is actually related to
the rise of analogy so let me show you a
little bit okay recently we've seen more
on more text to text model this was
studying by studied by this nice say
swap a paper by a bright Mac cane which
was called the natural language
decathlon it was a task it was a
benchmark where you have like 10 tasks
to take at home and you have to just
they were all cast in the same format in
the same framework they were all cast as
christian answering tasks so if you have
translation you would have a question
which is translate something translate
this from English to German and then you
have a context which is the English
sentence okay when you have
summarization we actually formulate that
as a textual input which is summarized
this and then you have the news example
a new model has to generate the output
has to generate the translators the
German translation it has to generate
the summarization so it's not
classification test like we saw before
but it's generation task
gbt - is a big model that makes a lot of
PR but was also very very nice paper
called multitask language Molalla
unsupervised multitask learners and
there was a lot of zero shot experiment
in this how do we do the shot with CPD -
you do the same you actually formulate
your task with a prompt which is fine
some
summarize or for summarization they did
what they what they could TLDR - too
long didn't read and then they put the
the sentence to summarize and the model
is a actually trying to generate is not
training so zero surety the model try to
generate some plausible completion and
the plausible completion will be a
summary
and gb2 is quite good at that a lot of
tasks can be formulated like that like
the Lambada data set which is very
interesting tasks where you try to
predict the last word and the last word
of sentence is something that is not
explicitly said in the beginning but
uses just implied for instance people
are talking about giving birth but you
don't say these the it's not explicitly
mentioned in the paragraph and at the
end you have to talk you have to
complete with the word pregnancy okay so
the model has to understand the
underlying meaning of the sentence to be
able to put in the right word so this is
completion tasks it can be formulated as
text generation where you generate the
next word and we've seen a rise of
models like this which are trained to
generate word and where we actually
recast our usual classification or usual
NLP tasks as test text to text
generation tasks okay and we've seen
that in a lot of recent model Facebook
birth model which pre trained with the
text to text objectives so it was pre
trained by giving it Corrib text where
you have like randomly dropped tokens
randomly dropped words or the text is
shuffled you can see all the the
objectives here and the mother is trying
to regenerate the clean text from that
okay so you can formulate this the
noising objective as a text to text
generation as a correct text to clean
text generation and they even train a
multilingual model called M board on
this so we we have this both model now
on transformer so you can try them and
this models they're trained in this
framework and the most famous one is the
recent t5 Google is mostly famous
because for some time with a short
amount of time it was the biggest mobile
so the 11 billion parameter model ant if
I'm is P trained and fine-tuned like
this it's pre trained with the noising
objective like the one with sofa board
and it's fine tuned in a text to text
format so for instance on blue tasks
like a manila I you have to pretty
contain my no contradiction and you will
have you will formulate your task as a
text input another we have to generate
entitlement the word on payment or the
world contradiction why is it great this
is great because with this we don't
really have to fine-tune any
lair okay we don't actually add any
layer to a model we take the same
architecture for pre-training and for
fine-tuning there is nothing to find you
in on to train from scratch which mean
that in theory we can do zero shot
because no weights needs to be
fine-tuned on the on the target task
okay the model is ready to be used on
the target task now usually this means
we need to do like target target task
inform for training like we need during
the pre training that's what is very
interesting in the t5 paper that you can
read as well during the pre train they
cannot doing for training the prepared
model for this test by giving some
example of the fine-tuning as well so
the model knows that it will be asked to
do some attainment or contradiction
between question but then you can have
zero shot and actually when you look at
what Sam Bauman is saying about glue and
superglue is their successor to this
task so that is actually really hard now
to find some data set where actually we
can have a good classification like a
good NLU task where you actually can
prevent this model to which human
preferences where this model don't even
already reach human performances and
usually they reach remain preferences
because they are taking advantage of
this fine-tuning task okay so in general
we should I think we should really focus
on zero shots adaptation for transfer
learning like zero shot of very few
sample efficiencies your adaptation okay
I hope that take away of all this disken
discussion